AO out with Jarvis and Bunting right point shot
Burns is blocked hit sticks Burns again on the
right wing down to the circle a shot and he
scores well Bren Burns has had two or three
decent looks early in the game he buries this
one one- nothing Carolina trying to make sure
they're trying to get it going right there the
shot breaks and snaps cop's stick so he's got to
drop it no longer able to get involved in the play
now again I think Kopitar was well away from the
shot when Burns took the shot watch Burns get
his head up here he always look at that that's
a great look with his head up he's not looking at
the goal thend he's looking for that open spot you
already get that feeling that Carolina is going
to make you make quick decisions quick plays and
sometimes you're not ready to make that play and
it doesn't connect their penalty kill second only
to Boston last year a turnover look out AO with
speed in decks scores short-handed goal Sebastian
AO decisions with the puck fala tried to make an
extra stick handle there is no one really behind
him at this point and there is the he just he over
skates the puck so it's not necessarily a decision
it's just lack of execution there by fiala and
then AO very smartly watch him use the momentum of
Copley against himself Copley has to move one way
opens up can opener Puck between the legs Quinton
Byfield just 21 the King's first round pick couple
of years ago two nothing Carolina a shot from the
base of the left Circle goes in coach neami and
that is one that CLE would like to have back three
nothing Carolina feel an atmosphere around the
king's team so cooking Yi gets to a spot where
he runs out of options and unfortunately that's
just one of those that that cannot go in does it
hit a stick I don't think it does you can see
that Copley is not balanced when he goes down
look at this he's moving his upper body went up
a little bit right there there's that size and
strength Mikey Anderson to fiala to dowy winds
a shot he score Drew Dy gets the Kings on the
[Music]
board so a different feel now maybe the Kings
certainly do not get anywhere near the start
they wanted fala finds it and very quickly that's
one of the keys passing and quick decision as soon
as fala gets that one he knows Dow he's open
Drew gets his head up hands it off they work
it in the middle but Jarvis fan as he put a move
on to get a shooting angle and get some more room
back quickly Lemieux to the circle shoots and
scores Brendan Lemieux the X King a goal early
in the second 4-1 Carolina stretch pass you got
to stop here look at the Kings they're all over
at the bench they're trying to come on the ice
in this area here and all of a sudden there's
the pass that's open now from from this point
on Lemieux he gets it going he has the speed
he ends up getting the shot to inside the dots
that's important right there watch him take it
bad angle watch him lean in short Side High fala
to dubba and a pass across for copar broken up
by a Carolina stick kopar for fialo one time
and it's Knocked Down K centers kopar [Music]
scores he had du had a a whole bunch of different
guys here and that makes it so important it goes
by Dua gets to Kopitar but when you have big
bodies down low like that and you can see how
Adrien bought himself some time there he spun
around we saw Puck protection to create the
penalty you see Puck protection here and you
go down to the ankle C play broken up fiala
to Duba off his stick now look out oh two on one
AO with Tera Bayan here's Tera scores Carolina's
second short-handed goal tonight they're up by
three once again and right here the Kings have a
chance with a now they have the turnover it's the
double cross everyone going one a tervin opens up
there he just opens up his body watch him left
side of the screen open that means give me the
puck and he wastes no time top Corner credit maybe
Carolina on a penalty kill being very aggressive
and have an active sticks Kings win the draw
set it up the youngster lefer out is more four
shoots and scores Trevor Moore Let It Go from the
left Circle it's a power play [Music] goal Deno
wins it first great back normally that gives
you time look at the pressure and then Trevor
Moore decides hey you know what guys it's early
on a power play and when it's early get the shot
on that if this doesn't go in across picked
up lazat to Roy a blast knock down and then
tipped fly gabov was in front with Anderson Dolan
gabov to Roy on the right side for Lazard off his
stick battling Anderson Dolan got it to lazat
spinning shooting block score deorov and it's
a one goal game really good offensive instincts
fight for a loose Puck get to loose Puck and
then you see back door now give v a lot of credit
here watch how he shoots his one timer but it's a
cross body [Applause] one-timer I don't think that
play was intended initially to go to gabov Lazard
on the turnaround spin he's calling H someone he
won't tell who he's calling then all the chances
happen after they get it copy to the bench 130
left and N to our right is empty Kings Trail in
front it comes shot cetar from brunstrom the Kings
have come all the way back we're tied at [Music]
five the simple play is get it yourself so
twice in a row it's Kee This Time by field
earlier and you know what nice hesitation here
by grundstrom watch what he gets it Grunst gets
it here he could have see that little [__] on
the wrists that just delated enough to open up
the lane oh yes as soon as the defender moved his
stick copar was open back door and we're tied at
five AO trailing has it AO moving into the
slot couldn't get around Byfield cleanly
and Spence will clear and this one will go to a
shootout tonight with his new team in on an angle
dubba [Applause] scores it's over the pad under
the blocker that's what you're doing and you can
see right there when he decided to shoot that's
just perfectly placed AO speeding in AO stopping
up gaks and scores well this is the technique
that many players use nowadays right there oh
yeah see that but the puck still going forward
and then at that point it's tough the golender
martinus must score or the Kings win NIS with
speed NIS scores first two times did not work
this one does is Nate just fak there and again
it's just just an open up with a stick look at
that you see the stick this time moves out of
the way right to story here the rookie lafier
moving in save is made yeah theier tried
to Mo make a move to deceive the golender
you'll see him open up his skates and his hips
right right there you see and then the goenda
doesn't buy it there's nothing with Anderson
taking his eye off the puck on the puck all
the way Jordan martinook the veteran forward
to win it martinook deakes and he scores and
the Hurricanes win the game and a shootout that
goes nine rounds here tonight in Los Angeles oh